[Musique]
ta haine et ça aurait espionné des
responsables politiques en europe dont
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
entre 2012 et 2014 et ce avec l'aide des
services de renseignements danois
on n'est pas dans un monde de bisounours
donc ce genre de comportement
malheureusement peut arriver on va le
vérifier voulait dire qu'on fait la même
chose avec les américains en jeudi que
simplement un travail doit y avoir
même si on n'est pas dans un monde de
bisounours une confiance une coopération
minimale il y a dix ans et services
secret et la msa ont scellé un accord
pour intercepter massivement les données
qui transitent par les câbles sous
marins notamment installé au fond de la
mer baltique et qui atterrissent au
danemark
est-ce qu'on va demander des comptes aux
américains voyagent voir effectivement
sur nos protestations diplomatiques mais
je le dis je crois qu'ils pour nos
alliés et amis américains si on se
comporte comme ça peut pas attendre
qu'ils aient une bonne coopération entre
les services
la msa a aidé à construire un centre de
stockage au sud de copenhague
en échange l'agencé américaine peut
l'utiliser pour son propre compte
ce n'est pas acceptable entre alliés il
n'y a pas de place entre nous pour le
soupçon
c'est pourquoi ce que nous attendons
c'est la carte est complète
il a fini par céder sous la pression des
forces d'élite les mêmes qui ont été
déployés lors de la traque des cévennes
il y a deux semaines selon les gendarmes
terry du pin ancien militaire âgé de 29
ans était dans une logique suicidaire
il a été neutralisé près d'une zone
résidentielle le premier flic de france
est un adepte des coups médiatiques des
coûts qui peuvent parfois se retourner
contre lui
en ligne de mire gérald darmanin est il
devenu un problème ou reste-t-il une
pièce maîtresse pour emmanuel macron
perry du pain et cerner mais refuse de
se rendre ils ouvrent le feu en premier
le gign riposte le fugitif est
grièvement blessé dès les premiers
mètres la procession est sifflée
interpellé par des manifestants
communards ses 300 personnes commémore
les quarante neuf otages de la rue haxo
dont dits religieux fusillé par les
fédérés il ya 150 ans c'est pas pour
rien qu'on le surnomme darmanin il est
vif
hal gill il est sur toutes les balles
assure un conseiller de l'elysée il vaut
mieux un mec qui fait des coûts qu'un
ministre qui n'imprime pas ajoute le
même
deux sexagénaires sont projetés au sol
l'un d'entre eux est hospitalisée suite
à sa blessure au crâne
les fidèles se réfugie dans cette église
pendant près d'une heure trente à paris
des gars de licques ont été prises à
partie par des individus violents en
marge d'une procession la liberté de
culte doit pouvoir s'exercer en toute
sérénité dans notre pays
pensé pour les catholiques de france il
faut vacciner et tous azimuts
l'arrivée de ces doses nous le permet la
mobilisation et la remarquable
organisation des centres de vaccination
rendre tout cela possible
c'est vrai que moi je suis pas au
rassemblement national donc c'est pas
tout à fait encore l air aidera ce
machin mais c'est une nouvelle digue qui
s'effondre et moi je rends hommage à
guillaume d'avoir osé dire ce qu un bon
nombre d'élus des républicains pensent
que de son plus proche de nous ils sont
plus proches de moi qui le sont de la
république au mans et nous en avons nous
en avons parlé à l'instant avec avec le
président nous avons la célébration
des oiseaux monsieur pelletier y rampe
vers l'extrême droite
je crois que c'est une désorientation
une honte pour un parti qui se dit
républicain et dont une partie
une partie des membres non des moindres
ne sait plus où il habite et pense que
c'est la surenchère à l'extrême droite
en proposant des choses que le
rassemblement national lui même ne
serait pas proposé qu'ils vont se
refaire une santé politique
il s'appelle libye à jeddah où adada
rapport à son cri insupportable qui fait
la daba bas et le programme de madame le
pen c'est le train qui fonce dans le mur
en klaxonnant et plus on parle fort
plus on a la garantie que tous se mirent
à naître